all right let's welcome to the next
level stage I heart of the city alum mr.
Marvin hunter what's up with you man
good to see you again man good to be
here let's go back to when you were 19
okay I want you to explain something to
me mm-hmm I got a picture explaining
this picture to me man a mixed-up guy
right hope you look happy about it too
what happened oh no no do you feel like
deflate you honed your comedy talents in
the Navy absolutely absolutely you have
to we had to find something break the
monotony
very serious stuff we deal with you know
the stupid shall be punished one of the
rules that I adopted earlier on so
stupid shall be discussed and punished
Wow did you do comedy shows all the Navy
I did not I did not but a round the
base I did once you got out there once
you started killing the scene mm-hmm
did your swag change a little bit on the
Navy ship little bit a little bit
everybody start looking at you yeah
during that time I was single you know
okay girls little bit of problem you
don't say hey the grumpy uncle thing
that you said is you adopted from your
father do you have that absolutely you
that guy was your kid absolutely 100%
yeah no nonsense man you don't know no
time to baby five people too much of
that going on no gray areas no gray
areas and on over here
how old is your kid he's 25 20 what and
it's still no grass no gray area they
grow up so slow literally watching you
on stage it's a breath of fresh air
because you have such a unique cadence
man and I think right now it is time for
you to go to the next level man there's
no reason for you to still be sitting
here go to the next level
[Music]